hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
Screen Rant 25 times and Marvel actors
went totally off script I don't know why
I called for that the best scripts lots
of do the spider thing crime-fighting
spider your spider boy howdy screen
Rangers welcome back in today's
marvelous video we're going to take a
juror when actors have improvised in
Marvel films and we're not just looking
at the MCU time to branch out into our
world of Marvel for the off-the-cuff
comments surprising dramatic moments and
you all up origin to a brain and
improviser punch writer strike more
rambling and let's get started
and sink since the first Avengers film
success we it turns out that the famous
and credit scene of our heroes sure
happened due to an improvised line I
heard about this jr. you were George
Foreman when Tony Stark falls back to
earth and is revived by the Hulk Stark
suggests the team gets shawarma
something that wasn't in the original
script director Joss Whedon loved it so
much that after filming had finished he
wanted that scene included only he had
to wait until the international premiere
to shoot it with a cast hence why
Captain America is covering his face in
the seat he had to hide his bearded face
with prosthetic makeup he needed the
facial balance for his role in
snowpiercer in the origin film Captain
America the First Avenger burned out a
mask in Easton Rogers became the shield
tossing super soldier of America after
he's been given the serum and emerges
from the container he's now the Buck
Rogers and Peggy Carter approaches the
chest Huxley can't hold back she
releases her inner Patrick and touches
caps pack it only happens for a brief
moment but it was when actors have an
excuse she just reacted in character the
crew loved it so much that they film
that scene several times without while
stroking Steve and they rehearsed it to
the incipio now an assistant which is
understandable because it is he is
extremely hungry and also has a high
fever don't forget that wasn't in the
script when actor Tom Hardy was on the
set he spotted the gigantic lobster tank
after many conversations with the film's
crew the scene was reject for Hardy's
wishes he was then allowed to dunk
himself into the tank with his car
stationed friends yeah he's requesting
in-between cakes
he would not Johnson treats Tony Stark
and Steve Rogers
talking in the lab on the shield
Helicarrier as the scene goes on star
pulls out some blueberries and begins
eating he then offers them to Boehner
and Rogers as it wasn't in the script
Chris Evans and Mark Ruffalo ideia
provides their characters reactions Joss
Whedon loved Downey's improv so much
that he had to keep it in the final cut
and the next Avengers movie was
sponsored by California farms
blueberries yes meaning we tried a
little bit from there ourselves
I don't think it was improv the script
supervisor must have hated Robert Downey
jr. that supposedly 80% of the film was
unscripted and that's coming from the
director himself so it comes as no
surprise that those moments within our
list as a way to disarm some guards Thor
would pretend Loki is injured and shout
for assistance only to cost locate the
guards and take them all out like some
form of Asgardian bowling it seems it's
a play that has happened many times
before there wasn't much faith in the
guardians of the galaxy fennel it was
first announced the second the hardcore
comic fans much of the audience hadn't
heard of the Space Needle so the actors
were given some freedom in order to push
their characters one such actor was
Chris Pratt as Peter quill in work seen
the group had been captured by the Nova
Corps as they're being put through the
system in the core men are discussing
each character's Mary it provides that
did you really watch a lot of these are
like iconic moments for for these films
yeah it's pretty crazy provides longer
shows proof of his parental lineage and
Jordan muttered the line auntie Angela
Bassett confirmed in an interview was
indeed that's pretty crazy
[Laughter]
Tony's attempting to recruit gear for
his side the Spyder Ling crime-fighting
spider spider boy during the scene the
two characters switch from walking to
city many times when it came to Tony's
turn to sit down he could Tom Halden
and his leg on the bed in character
Robert Downey jr. had to improvise by
stating I'm gonna sit here so you move
the leg
he goes to show how well he knows his
character pretty impressive they need
many mutants who showcase their powers
and are persuaded to join their team one
can be evil brothers huge Wolverine this
interaction was actually improvised by
the Australian actor himself Xavier and
Magneto
track down Logan in a bar as he's
quietly drinking whiskey and puffing on
a cigar the two approach and introduce
themselves from 2011 store and stores
any campaign with Jane Foster and Darcy
Louise he's enjoying his drink so much
that he checks the cup onto the ground
for Matt this is a compliment lesson
however Hemsworth was the only actor
that knew this was going to happen he
felt it would encapsulate it provides
that yeah that's crazy
there's like big moment movies when
Steven stranger former surgeon joins the
magical elite he brings with him some
pop culture knowledge when he's
attempting to get some books on astral
projection and bumps into Wong who is
the keeper of the magical library long
tell Stephen that he's not ready to
learn from these books since Wong has
only one name Stephen retorts with try
me
Beyonce this line was actually added in
by Benedict Cumberbatch later on when
Stephen steals the books Wong is shown
listening to single ladies by Beyonce
probably is research whose Gamora Drax
who is lying on the floor thanks to
stark chimes in with I'll do you one
better
why is Gamora the answer the hi Drax
Dave Bautista confirm that he
spontaneously came up with the memorable
line after the line was uttered it
became one of the most famous lines from
infinity I wonder what the original is
seems like it's the perfect one two
three skills in the impro heavy thor
ragnarok but prior to the 2017 film
Ruffalo would test the improvisational
waters in 2012's Avengers film during
Bruce banners debut Black Widow tracks
down the reclusive scientist in an empty
house Natasha
the recruit Banner and the Hulk to
tackle the low key problem during the
scene banner would say well I do feel
low-key introduced in 2016 Black Panther
film sure II would be known as range
behind will exactly have an improvised
bounced off to chihuahua effortlessly
one area in which she was able to
brandish your character was when an
injured Everett Ross was brought in to
chala wanted to use his country's tech
to save the CIA age when Cherie sees
what her brother brought her latisha
decided to add in a line of her own
Avenger stuff again in the future
Tony leans over Peter so and her hugs
him only for Tony to say it's not a hug
grab the door for you mr. stark Tom
Hollands hug wasn't in the original
script he started to be funny to embrace
brownie as he reached across rowdy there
were low expectations by the audience
when ant-man was released you could say
little instead it comes from scenes
involving Scott Lang his ex Maggie and
her fiance Jim Paxton the actors in the
film improvised all the awkward family
dynamics involving them Judy Greer who
played Maggie he spoke in an interview
about how much fun they had devising the
scenes she also apologized to the editor
for all of their laughing in the scenes
Tobey Maguire was the first to play
spider-man on the big screen you decided
to go web-shooter she cares fun fact the
comics did a whole complicated story to
mirror the film's web-shooters he's
turned into a giant spider parish's then
bursts out of a spider body as a human
again but with new powers comics can be
weird anywho in Sam Raimi's film Spidey
stands on top of a building and those
various hand movements as well as
shouting commands literally up for many
of those commands came in the form of DC
character references
I'm up and away all the hand movements
and commands were added in by McGuire
himself Rainey let his star get creative
in this fun scene Shakespearean
legendary thespian Kenneth Branagh
directed the first Thor film in 2011 in
the early part of the film Thor gathers
a small team and goes against his father
and Kings wishes to attack the frost
giants only for Odin to turn up and save
their bacon afterwards
Odin verbally lays into Thor and his
arrogant ways Brahma allowed anthony
hopkins to put his own take on the
character of odin hopkins improvise the
speech that opening games as he banishes
Thor even the animalistic growl at Loki
was popped in by Hopkins the scene was
powerful and showed Hopkins immense
acting abilities years of harassing Fox
executives Ryan Reynolds finally got his
wish of a solo but most of this movie I
know in particular during the scene
after Deadpool shows his newly
disfigured face to Wiesel many of the
insulting quips were improvised by
Miller like an avocado due to all of
Miller's legal issues and controversies
he probably won't be included when
Disney takes over the Deadpool franchise
but he isn't underwater when the Iron
Man film was announced rogdon confusion
about why they'd want to watch a movie
about a robot yep that's exactly what
they thought Jon Favreau the director of
the film and Robert Downey jr.
immediately changed the audience's
apathy
it would start the launch of the MCU
otherwise where would we be at screen
ride without the MCU near the end of the
film it's totally the most audience we
would hear the immortal line a line that
would also signal the end of Tony in the
Marvel Universe during endgame you might
be intrigued to know that it was
actually an impromptu line by Downey and
Iron Man what
was a critical and financial success I
guess we've got a sequel set up stealing
your event unknown power stone he's
apprehended by Corinth in France as
things are getting tense quill says that
they might know by another name
star-lord only to be greeted by ooh
quill is obviously very disappointed
that his alias doesn't actually have the
reputation he thought it did this part
was suggested by Chris Pratt is a fun
meta moment with many scenes from being
opened up for spontaneous dialogue the
actors could flex their thespian muscles
as Thor is caught and forced into the
gladiatorial area he's greeted by the
person he's fighting which turns out to
be hulk thor cheers with the review and
says to the Grandmaster we know each
other he's a friend from work this
amazing line didn't come from the minds
of the actors or crew however instead a
child from the make-a-wish Foundation
suggested the line when they were
visiting the same oh oh gosh now under
one of the most heart-wrenching scenes
in infinity war sorry all on the bright
side it kind of worked out for the
character in the end kinda of course
we're rambling about it's spider-man and
his dusting according to one of the
directors Joe Russo the lines in the
scene with Peter and Tony were
improvised there and then including the
lines of mr. stark I don't feel so good
and I don't want to go as he begs Tony
to help them one of the most
tear-jerking scenes in the whole of the
MCU wasn't even scripted now we finish
off with the latest spontaneous acting
moment in the MCU from avengers endgame
as Iron Man returns to earth his life
has been turned upside down as he was
recovering a question from Captain
America and Thanos cause Tony to snap he
verbally laid in the cap and finishes
off by calling the Super Soldier a liar
the last part was added in by Robert
Downey jr. in order to have the passion
of the scene and Tony's anger Downey
chose to add in one small word it was
enough to some of his character that
point also down you would tailor the
famous I Love You 3000 line after
experiences with his kids
Danya was on an emperor
enroll in his wife's MCU appearance and
that's a wrap
thanks for sticking around to the end
coming off his way through the entire
cycle the most iconic moment is like
kicked off the event you is an improv
cab most of the iconic moments are just
stemmed from him Reverend the warmest so
many of these were just like what he
improvised that I mean this schwarmann
line I can see how the shawarma line is
improvised based off of how the scene
works in Joss Whedon style but the fact
that he gave us this iconic post-credits
scene I remember watching it arrow was
bursting in a laughs this is such a
reference post-credit moment and it all
stemmed from the idea of him just
talking about swarm up or one little
joke it could have been a Burger King it
could have been any kind of tapas
because Chavez is so randomly specific
yeah Hayley Atwell touching gropings
chest Chris Evans yeah that wouldn't fly
by well in if it was gender role
reversed I'm just saying what it would
not so why is it okay for Haley out well
I say we're cancelling Haley Atwell
let's let's let's make sure she never
works ever and she never uses those
hands for anything ever again I'm using
it as an excuse because you're in the
scene to touch someone like that yeah
not cool probably worked out what your
boundaries are beforehand but ya can't
expect us to know that mm-hmm although I
will come to Jared Leto's defense it was
okay to send dead rats and condoms to
his castmates got stay in character you
know I've seen Avengers assembles a few
times I don't really remember that
moment where he has a package of
blueberries but I feel like you figured
to include an additional property you're
just gonna piss off your scripts masa
kind of thing's gotta be crinkly exactly
all this bag the wrappings I guess I
mean I'm sure they're audio engineers
are so high-tech they can isolative it's
still it's it's still a [ __ ] to work
around oh yeah don't present some issues
plus yeah you got everybody
eating in the scene you never
potentially eating anyway that might not
be a big moment or even an iconic moment
stands out to me because those are
actually hard to work around as opposed
to some random line that was improvised
it's very hard for me to believe that
80% of thor ragnarok was improvised I
feel like the dialogue was I don't think
the situation's really were it's
probably just the most expensive version
of a Curb Your Enthusiasm episode where
there's how the beginning middle and end
has to go not just in terms of act 1 act
2 3 but every single scene and then you
could kind of wiggle your way around a
lot of the dialogue and stuff and have a
lot of fun there I think when you say
80% of it was improvised I think it just
sounds like they made up like the whole
movie they ran the movie through the
math they calculator and they're like
how much of this was in the script and
there you go 80% it does I guess in that
case seemed kind of weird to include
Ragnarok more than once just because
it's not even just like a momentous yeah
the entire movie although I did really
enjoy the Make A Wish one about the yeah
work like I thought that was a sweet
wonderful thing to have happen to you I
wonder if that kid got to see the movie
when I came out what surprised me about
those lists as so many of these moments
are iconic moments star-lord giving the
finger that was one of the most standout
moments in the trailer when it first
first that's a hilarious moment and it's
one of the it's a it became a meme on
even the Thor like another like that's
all yes or no there yeah moments from a
movie those two good specific like
little jokes are or standouts in the
trailer and became like things that
people quota or memed it's pretty insane
to know like these actors really do
contribute creativity here right I'll
just go in there and say their lines and
elaborative collaborative yeah Benedict
Cumberbatch said Beyonce yeah changed
all the Doctor Strange even Michael be
turned to saying hey aunty aunty yeah
that's such a tense scene and it
elevates it to us weird humor and I
think it makes it kind like a little bit
more likable it seems like such a little
lie is so at home kill mongers a villain
the whole scenes tense but when he says
hey auntie everyone laughed in the
theatre yeah and I think that
automatically sways you - I like this
guy sharp
yeah seriously yeah
a little one like that makes the biggest
difference kudos damn because that's a
line that I feel like could have gone
wrong or something or broke in that
scene but it does truly add like a weird
he's the only calm guy in the room yeah
Tom Hardy going into the tank I'm glad
we got clarify I can't really say that
off script though right especially when
he ran it by them I feel like this list
led me to believe that he would have
just jumped in or something yeah it'd be
like oh I've got this idea can we clear
this is this something we did yeah this
actually becomes part of the script at
that hoping I'll give it to them only in
the sense that I guess this was a
spontaneous thing that happened on the
day all these things it's not something
that they just randomly captured in
camera that then became oh we're gonna
use that take it was like this was
premeditated and probably very well
prepped because you can't have him
jumping in and crushing a lot there's
two dead in the Wolverine line in x-men
first class I think it's pretty cool to
how they let them get the one line with
an F word popular moment because it's
the one momo'o Vereen
and it's even quoted in x-men days of
future past and I'm gonna say to you
what you said to us then I love when
they make their way into the Canon that
way like they'll the little references
come back why is Gamora line was so
famous I heard about that being it
provides the long-ago but like I said
like what especially cuz the camera pans
down and there's definitely a line that
was there her that he had to say oh s---
the camera we're gonna pan down him yeah
that's like a digital pan down yeah or
something yeah my best guess would just
be that it would be an answers like more
as this person or as the daughter of
fattest man in robot suit I actually
really appreciate the sherry improvise
line another white boy to fix there's no
broken white boy with the cliffhanger of
Civil War showing that Winter Soldier is
gonna be Bucky's gonna be saying in what
Conda Bucky shows up in the post-credits
scene yeah a black panther you know he's
not in the film I don't even really a
member of that post-credit I've seen the
movie a couple times it's sure you in
that post-credit scene I shouldn't
remember either way that shows Leticia
Wright's
sensibility and understanding of this
movie and world yeah - without that line
like that hey you know and
so naturally it shows like a fan side of
her yeah able to say that and even like
another iconic like from fire like from
homecoming when yeah the hug yeah
because it sounds like that was a part
of it or like I'm not hugging him was
going for the door but for him to like
reciprocate yeah that makes it that much
more uncomfortable yeah yeah that's when
I had heard of it but I'm always happy
to know that that was like a natural
moment I really do appreciate how much
this is proving cuz I've noticed that in
just a weird little shorts and stuff
that we've made over time is often the
mistake or the random thrown out thing
is the spontaneity that you need yeah no
seriously I am Iron Man line that blows
my mind that he improve on is that I
can't because that's like the segue into
the sequel when everyone knows who if
there wasn't that line and then they did
Iron Man 2 whatever it is like hey what
everyone know I have ruined the illusion
I make you go oh I guess he every one
knows but they must have come up with
the idea of Iron Man 2 because of that
line it goes to the credit of the MCU I
guess for really going one movie at a
time I had heard this was an improvident
blew my mind at the time but I'm still
boggled because it seems like such a
significant thing to throw out at the
very end of your movie and then
everybody around had to go hold on a
minute we can work with this you know
and yeah it had to have affected like
that in and of itself is like Robert
Downey jr. has affected the MCU since
it's sorta like him revealing his Hermes
more just plots up that also showed us
that oh it's gonna be different if super
our movies because it's always like I
got to conceal my identity identity he
set himself a party set the universe
apart well this was a great list Thank
You scream raft for putting this
together very improvised moments we
don't know about that weren't let's
let's comment below you guys can
subscribe to scream wrath subscribe to
the real rejects please click that
notification mail you notify would never
got a video up I like to end this with a
patron of the day shout out to a lovely
woman named Adelia Chamberlain I mean
dealer what more can i really say we
have so many long engaging conversations
I feel like things have been better for
you as of late but unfortunately you
have told me recently this happened with
the Star Wars movie or is it Avengers 1
remember right now you have to have foot
surgery so you had to avoid I think it
was last Jedi last Jedi and then now
this new Star Wars Raisa Skywalker she's
gonna be on a trip so she won't be able
to catch rise of Skywalker do on time
you're such a star well Star Wars look
I'm sorry that you're gonna have to
really work adamantly to make sure you
do not get Star Wars spoiled for you so
tell you what we talk in messages a lot
I'll just ruin it for you I'll watch it
on opening night and I'll instantly
message you I'll tell you everything you
need to know that way you don't have to
worry about avoiding social media for
you know however long you have to so you
watch Star Wars in the theaters I got
you covered that's what friends are for
and then I'm gonna jump into the box and
try and convince you that he's lying and
then no don't listen to him and don't
don't read the comments and that's not
what happens at all good you should go
see the movie still John you need a
fingerprint identification and retina
scan in order to access the message of
the messages I also needed to access the
office door the bathroom door in the
front door it's hard to be here a lot
the chats not about you it's about a
Delia and she's lucky she's not here
she doesn't here EndNote scammed it
access it oh why is it just me really
need to tell you